ANDREW BROGDON: Creating an
ad unit in the AdMob user
interface only
takes a few clicks,
but there's actually
a lot of work
that goes on under the hood.
For example, AdMob has
servers and data centers
all over the world.
So when you create a new ad
unit, information about it
gets propagated
thousands of miles away,
which is both really cool
and slightly time consuming.
It can actually take up to an
hour for a new AdMob ad unit
to fully spin up
around the world.
In the meantime, you'll get
an error code from the SDK
if you try to
request ads from it.
The good news is
that if you need
to work on your code in the
meantime, Test Ads still serve.
You can turn them on
using the test devices
parameter in your
ad requests, or use
one of the dedicated
Test Ad unit
IDs you find in our
implementation guides.
So there's no need to slow down.
[MUSIC PLAYING]